how is the private jet business doing it
was flying a year later a little
different story sounds way different
story and then at one point people were
asking to pay in Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency are they doing that [ __ ]
now or no
I spent a lot of time in Africa as well
talk a little bit about what you guys
are doing there and I believe it that's
like gonna be like the Ibiza for Africa
you know not only Africa is a place
where you can live and where you can
reside at but you also do business
there's kind of a whole genre of like
afrobeats that seem to be blowing up on
the global stage what's driving you know
afrobeats I call it I think it's
uplifting music where even though if you
don't understand the words it makes you
feel good what are the business
opportunities you see whether it's in
Ghana or kind of broader Africa what are
the big areas where you would tell them
to go look all right guys what's up bang
bang PJ Kev in the house what's up man
I'm pretty good how you feeling how is
the private jet business doing that's
what I want to talk about first it was
fine it was flying in 2021 everyone was
fussed with cash everyone was getting
rich everyone wanted a private jet
people were renting Jets they were
buying Jets you came in you were
explaining the whole thing I was like
damn all these dudes got Jess they must
be rich a year later a little different
story sounds way different story I mean
um people are still flying uh
um it's still been uh sort of busy I
think right now it's probably down about
20 okay from what it was last year uh
same type of people are still renting
Jets just 20 less of them or has it
changed a little it has changed a little
bit
um people are more conservative now when
it comes to just spending on Jets you
know they're now looking in you know
first class options and things like that
but it is busy around this time they got
less cash they got to look where it's
going right it is busy around this time
because of holidays
um so it's always picks up from I would
say like beginning of November until
like the end of like you know Jan to Feb
okay and then it slows down again how
have prices changed because there's 20
less demand have prices come down 20 or
not really the honestly prices hasn't
come down yet um we're still waiting for
I mean few has come down a little bit I
think it's down about 10 to 15 percent
but how much does it cost to go from
Miami to uh let's say New York City
right now right now on a G4 you probably
cost about anywhere from like 26 000
thirty thousand okay uh on like a mid
size it'll be anywhere between like 12
to like 18 around that range but
um you know before I remember when New
York to Miami was 15 grand you know to
17 grand on a G4 so we haven't doubled
business yeah so we haven't seen that
yet but um it's definitely coming down
I'll say yeah it'll come down and then
at one point people were asking to pay
in Bitcoin or cryptocurrency are they
doing that [ __ ] now or no no
Street dollars straight guys yeah I mean
you know with everything going on in
cryptocurrency a lot of uh people just
decided to you know just transfer their
money out into like usdt or usdc and
just hold yup
um you know before I was accepting
Bitcoin ethereum and you know other uh
coins I'm like nah so you won't even
accept the other stuff now nah I'm just
right now just USD till usdc I won't
accept btco ethereum right now what
percentage of customers are paying in
stable coins versus like just
traditional dollars well for me mean
well last year compared to that it was
probably about 40 percent of people was
paying with crypto wow you know I mean a
lot of people was paying crypto now I
mean nobody yeah yeah nobody so and then
are has there been a change in like uh
where people are flying from or to have
you seen like an increase in certain
cities or a decrease in certain cities
no not really but
um I think it's all about you know
what's going on and different I mean
people are still coming out of Miami
Miami has not really changed I see a lot
of people now flying into like Aspen a
lot uh but that always been like a busy
city
um hasn't really changed as much and so
this is all renting Jets what about uh
the price of the private jet like if
someone to buy an actual plane has that
changed at all yes people actually are
still looking to buy to take advantage
of the tax credit believe it or not
um but I think you know next year the
tax uh bracket turns until 80 so you
won't be able to write off 100 yeah yeah
eighty percent uh
so people are still trying to take
advantage of that they're trying to rush
in before the end of the year right try
to rush him before the end of the year
um there's not much availability out
there I think that will open up next
year sometime in the first quarter uh
there's a lot of people trying to get
rid of the assets and things like that
doing to the market
um but yeah it's it's it's been a steady
race you know I'm really steady and you
spent a lot of time in Africa as well
talk a little bit about what you guys
are doing there and like why are you so
interested in in Ghana well I'm from
Ghana and I believe that's like going to
be like the leading
um you know destination such as like the
Ibiza for Africa I believe you know when
it comes to entertainment when it comes
to real estate I believe like the demand
is going high and high and higher so for
me personally I decided to build
apartment complex this is in Ghana so I
already built one 12 units uh in
basically a West legon area in Ghana and
I'm now just uh basically just focusing
on real estate out there right now I
think you know the demand of you know
people want to to go back home just to
you know see Africa to visit Africa to
figure out where they're from their
Heritage uh you know a lot of people
were going there to see like the cape
Coast castle and see like how to how the
slaves were enslaved and things like
that with the history so a lot of people
are going to Africa believe it or not
just to get that sense of like history
that belief or they just want to party
yeah so talk to me about in Ghana
specifically how similar or uh different
is it than Nigeria Nigeria is the only
uh country
um that really like I would consider
from a western perspective that I've
gone to uh that people back if they say
they're going to Africa right Nigeria
and when I went to Lagos one of my big
tables people are so happy there yeah
right and especially when you come from
the Western World and then you go and
you see Nigeria like you're like man
this is so different than a New York
City a Miami or whatever just in terms
of infrastructure the way people live
like also but damn are these people
happy and like they're so just like it
sounds stupid but like there's like a
vibe to it right right and you're kind
of like yo I like this place right right
is Ghana very similar to that Ghana is
similar to that people are happy but Don
is more chilled than oh interesting than
Nigeria I think Nigeria is kind of like
the New York City yeah and I would say
like Ghana is more like a la mixed with
a Miami that makes sense because they
definitely still like to party you know
what I mean everybody loves the party
I've seen your Instagram stories
yeah we love the party but it's more
chilled and more relaxed and people are
happy you know believe it or not even
though they have little they have you
know not as much as we have in the
Western World they just it's just like
an energy that that we just have that we
just I don't know we just happy
creatures we just you know I think it's
of course is the weather I always say
like anywhere is like hot people are
like more nice but just our culture we
just more like you know just happy
people and then uh when you say it's
more entertainment this is like
nightclubs and music venues like the
nightclub herbs you have festivals a lot
of festivals going on I actually own the
festival out there my partners called
upfest in Ghana right now and um yeah
just a lot of people just you know won a
party so there's a nightclub scene yeah
the restaurant scene that's going crazy
now in Ghana which is kind of like
that's like a new brunch Vibe and party
vibe that you know a lot of people are
like you know going to but yeah there's
a lot of festivals going on
um just to name a few afrocella you have
affiliation you have afro cellos I think
yeah afro cell is it like that
yeah um shout out to them they they're
my people said really really cool but
yeah so like we you know we are just
trying to bring you know people back
home and to like realize that you know
not only Africa is a place where you can
live and when you can reside at but you
also do business how much of uh agana's
like rise in popularity business
economic uh uh impact maybe in Nigeria
as well is what I'll call uh natives who
never left versus natives who left and
now we're coming back versus uh somebody
who actually never has lived or was born
in one of these countries to be honest
with you the natives that left and came
back are the people that are thriving
the most they're driving a lot of this
they're driving a lot of this okay now
the natives that lived there personally
they are basically trying to adjust to
the new change because they've been
stuck in their ways for just so long
um and then mostly it's just like a
referral so like if I go to honor and I
tell you like hey I know that we can
make you know x amount of dollars doing
this real estate flip and you'd be like
okay what really have you done it before
yes I show you the numbers you're like
well these numbers are really really
impressive and then you come back and
you bring your team so I think it's just
basically everybody just sharing
information and that's just so important
right now just just the information that
you receive when you go to Ghana and
it's all about who you go to Ghana with
that's super important as well let me
explain that more so who do you go to
Ghana with is super important because
you get to see different perspectives uh
like for me if I take you to Ghana yes
I'm gonna show you the entrepreneurial
way I'm gonna show you different
business ventures that you can get into
but I'm also going to show you the
nightlife I'm also going to show you the
festivals I'm going to introduce you to
people that are really moving and
shaking in Ghana now if you go to
someone that just wants to have a good
time all you do is spend money and just
have a good time so it's a different
perspective that you get the Outlook of
of Ghana when you actually go there with
different people and how how much is
this like most countries I've been to
where there's urban areas there's rural
areas there's uh kind of the business
area of a city like is it very similar
in that in that sense or is it more kind
of flat and there's less uh maybe
contrast between uh you know the most
extremes of wealth and poverty within a
country yeah I mean
places like Ghana and Nigeria you are
going to see a significant wealth Gap
um I think now it's changing to somewhat
of a middle class because a lot of
people from you know Europe and and a
lot of people from America is actually
moving back so you still have that like
that middle class but you do see it is a
large wealth guy yeah right this large
wealth Gap in the United States too
right but but I think part of what
people from the Western world uh were
ignorant like we don't we if you've
never gone I've never gone to Ghana I
don't know what it's like and so there's
almost this like perception whether it's
from the media or things you read online
or whatever I see the more that you can
understand hey it's probably more
similar than different right in a lot of
ways uh I think it helps people realize
like uh uh we're all human right the
human experiences is pretty similar and
I guess like is remote work and like
online businesses and stuff is that
having a big impact or not really yeah
actually right now a lead-in uh industry
that I've been looking to get into a
defintech industry that's been having a
serious huge impact in uh just Africa
period but online businesses are
starting to come out there I mean
Twitter had their headquarters in in
Ghana for a while before the shutdown
um so yeah I mean you you do have
businesses that's looking to jump into
the African space I think that you know
we're not there yet but in the future
for sure we'll definitely get there and
are there people who are moving back
from the United States or kind of other
uh places whether it's in Europe or uh
the Western World and they're saying hey
I must keep working at these large tech
companies but I'm just going to do it
back from uh Ghana or is that not so
much what people are doing yeah you have
a percentage of people that actually are
doing that I think covet really help
people to understand that you can really
work
um effectively from home right so you
can live anywhere as long as you have
Wi-Fi and you know you have the time
schedule because you know we're six
hours ahead in Ghana so long as you have
the time schedule that adjusts as well
if you're you know flexible with your
work schedule you can definitely work
anywhere around the world so most people
will say okay I'll keep the steady
income that I have in America but I'll
just move to Ghana so I'm able to number
one take this money that I'm making in
dollars and I'm able to scale it because
you know we have a city right now we we
we spend money in cities which is the
Ghana currency if you're making in that
in dollars right now your dollars is 15
to 1 which is a it's just a big gap
right so now for your one dollar you'll
be spending 15 cities so you know that's
that's a large gap so now you're able to
spend more do more you're able to invest
a little bit more and um I think that's
why I'm post most people understand that
okay if I can continue to make my income
whether it's in the Western World
whether it's in you know Europe whether
it's Germany whatever it is and I could
take that income to Ghana I could be
able to invest more I can do more things
out in Ghana those people are living
like kings yeah
yeah
like what what uh what is the person
let's just say has like an average tech
salary uh or maybe 150 000 probably like
the average salary uh across all you
know uh levels of seniority plus uh
roles what does that buy you in Ghana
like are you like yo I got a 12 bedroom
mansion I got you know a full staff I
got you know six cars like I mean to be
honest Ghana is coming pretty expensive
so if you like basically the equivalent
to someone here making you know 60 to 80
000 in Ghana US Dollars can take you a
long way right but don't get it don't
get it twisted gonna now are charging in
US dollars
so you know what I mean you you have to
really I mean it all depends on your
lifestyle as well too right but I mean
you do have to make a significant amount
of money to live in Ghana even though
you know they still make it work with
the little that they have which is so
impressive when you see is like I can
buy you know with a hundred cities I can
buy my food I can use it for
transportation and I can save a little
bit I don't know how they do it but they
do it you know what I mean but
um to your point you don't need to make
a substantial amount of money to to live
there but you do have to I'll say at
least make 50 50k a year so you can live
comfortable right I mean and that's a
big number right even in the United
States that's higher than the average uh
salary right and so it's uh it's not
quote-unquote dirt cheap as there's a
lot of people in America who would say
uh almost moved to Thailand or you know
pick your your place around the world
that people seem to gravitate towards
because they think it's you know
incredibly inexpensive right this
doesn't sound like it's that but you can
make a decent living and also correct
kind of have the nice things in life as
well for sure yeah for sure um talk to
me about the music I was telling you
earlier that uh in 2016 maybe or so I
went to Nigeria and I met CK uh he was
not CK that he is now
um and uh I've seen his rise and it's
been incredible to watch kind of uh from
afar uh and now he's doing you know uh
multi-country tours and like all stuff
but his music uh there's kind of a whole
genre of like afrobeats there's a couple
of these uh different genres or or
artists that seem to be blowing up on
the global stage what's driving that I
think to be honest with you the sounds
that we are hearing now
um you know we in Africa we like to use
a lot of instruments right so I think
the instruments that we're using is
gravitating to the vibe into like the
the uplifting music you know afrobeats I
call it I think it's uplifting music
where it allows you to dance again
allows you to feel good so that energy
with the instruments and like the live
band I think all that came from Africa
which is transitioning to the Western
world but I kind of knew it was already
going to be like this when it comes to
like music-wise because I already seen
the transition when I was traveling to
London when I was going to Dubai and I
started to like yeah afrobeats I was
like okay the next you know the next
real music shift has to be afrobeat and
um people like burning boy DeVito and
Wizkid has basically changed that sound
to uplifting music it made people like
even though if you don't understand the
words it makes you feel good you know
what I mean and that's super duper
important especially this day and age
where you know you kind of want to have
uplifting music so you could go about
your day a little bit better so I think
that just comes with like the
instruments that comes with like the
different sound and people are like just
I guess getting tired of like the same
old kind of music that they've been
hearing for over the past years they
want to hear something new when that
afrobeats and that afrofusion is just
like taking over yeah is it almost
sounds like the music geographically
moves right like it starts in Africa on
the continent and then all of a sudden
it ends up in Europe and London Dubai
like you know what I mean and then
you're like hey it's going to migrate to
the U.S is there something to that or is
that just me being an idiot it's just
it's just people it's people just
transitioning like you come to Ghana
right but you don't live in Ghana you go
back to London you tell a friend Hey I
just heard this new CK song I just heard
this new burner Boy song Whiskey song
take a listen to it they like it and
it's just like especially with social
media around like you could get the
music out way faster you know what I
mean because of because of just a lot of
people are tuned into what new sound is
in is coming out so you know when you
when you hear like a burning boy last
live with a sample on it you know what I
mean it's like oh [ __ ] I could I could
relate to it you know mean and it's like
it's just now like it's just
transitioning you know what I mean it's
just like I mean look look what whiz
can't do with Essence it's just it was
like a global global hit everybody was
playing that song so
um there's a number of songs like this
in this uh kind of broader genre that uh
when I've seen them blow up I said to a
friend like CK is the one that yeah
obviously I think I've paid attention to
the most just because I met him
um and I said oh do you know who that is
I'm like nah and I'll play the song like
I heard that before exactly and so it's
interesting how in the U.S people maybe
like they may know the artist but they
don't actually know the song you hear it
almost is in Reverse yeah I think that
that that will change soon you know I
mean that's just repeated you know they
got a hair more they got to put a face
to a name that would change soon
um who are the who are the big artists
right now that you're like if you had if
you were a betting man I put like four
or five artists that you're like yo
these are the people who are gonna blow
up I think right now I would say Burna
Boy he's he's he's did amazing he's
doing amazing still whiz kid DeVito
um is a Nigerian artist called Ascot SK
okay he's he's doing really really
amazing like new sounds and to be honest
with you South South Africa South
African uh artists I don't know all
their names but they're blowing up too
as well yeah they have a new sound
called ammo piano and like when I went
to Ghana I started like hearing this
like new like instrument kind of like
whistle blowing and like it's crazy how
like that scene is actually blowing up
as well
um but yeah just to name a few I think
you know it's definitely more out there
in Ghana like the stone boys and other
people that blowing up as well but you
know just to name a few but it's it's a
lot of people that's channeling into
this direction of music and I think they
will do definitely well in the future
how much of this uh is similar to the
United States so I watched a documentary
I'm dangerous I got the internet because
I watched a documentary uh I think it is
uh the home or like the creation point
of drill music all comes from Chicago
from I think oh block yeah that's what
we call it right
um and it was basic from what I
understood it was like five or six
friends that each kind of blew up
individually somewhat in sequence uh but
it came out of uh gang battles
essentially right like there was one uh
uh project versus another project that
was close by and actually one of the
first songs that blew up uh and one of
the guys went on a global tour off of
was like basically a Battle Cry for this
block versus the other yeah yeah and so
like when you see that you're like oh
[ __ ] in the documentary they said
they're like yo basically there's a
bunch of white kids who were all singing
this like Battle Cry for a gang in
Chicago yeah and they had no clue
because they were going to a concert
they liked the music whatever
but what struck me was like there was
five or six ten well however many it was
all in one neighborhood and there's like
a probability aspect to it right it was
just like how I was born here I never
left here we're all friends right you're
16 I'm 14 that guy's 21 whatever you pop
he pops I pop like next you know this
music is global right is that what's
happening here too is like these people
all grew up together or is it maybe not
as uh serendipitous well not as
um not as significant as like how you
said but basically like more of just
coming from you know is almost 200
million people in Nigeria right so we'll
be more than the United States by 2050.
yeah it's just a lot of people in
Nigeria a lot a lot of young people with
internet access that understand how to
use mobile phones exactly so they they
they're coming from Nigeria and I think
drill music actually started in London
when I used to go to London like you
know 20 you know 17 2018 I used to hear
I used to hear that music I just didn't
really like it wasn't really my favorite
kind of music I didn't really listened
to it but drill music actually I think
started from London and then it
transitioned to you know the Western
world again I think everything always
starts first like overseas right really
what do you think that is
um I don't know because when I I usually
like hear stuff first when I go overseas
then you know the Western World I don't
I don't know if they have said Americans
don't have good taste no I'm not I just
think the producers are different I
think you know it comes with like the
society I think it just all that plays a
factor right
um but from my understanding
um the music out of Nigeria and South
Africa
are the leading music right now because
they have positioned yourself to Market
to the world I think Ghana
uh we we gone in you know as you know
Ghanaian artists they have trouble of
marketing to the world now they're
popular in Ghana don't get it twisted
they're really really popular in Ghana
but to the world I think they lack that
marketing what do you think is like the
if you could wave a magic wand and
change what would help them be able to
be uh globally recognized
to be honest with you it just comes with
a strategic you know online presence
um doing more shows internationally
um and just connecting with you know
producers all around the world and not
just in Africa
um I think you know if I could change
anything I'll just be saying hey I'll
just start up a marketing company and
say hey I like the market African you
know artists to America and I'll be the
company there but you know I'm not
really positioned right now to jump into
the music industry I will pretty soon
um I just have a lot on my plate but I'm
thinking about definitely helping out in
the music industry in some way how um
how much of the dream if you owe if
you're a music artist uh in one of these
African countries is to get out of that
country and get into the U.S market get
into the European market uh Middle
Eastern Market versus their still you
know young people who say hey if I
dominate in Ghana or I dominate in
Nigeria like that is a really important
Milestone and is I could build a career
off of just that anything past that
maybe icing on the cake but like that's
big enough of a market and enough for me
to build my career and I'd be happy with
that I think Africa is definitely a big
of a big enough a market to build just
there
um but I think every artist's dream is
to have their music all around the world
globally right you want people in
Australia to know you want people in
Dubai you want people in America so I
think they look at the American you know
culture like hey this is my dream and if
I make it here then you know I made it
but it is still some artists out there
that's dominating Africa in general
that's making a killing and um just
doing tours around Africa you know going
to you know Tanzania Kenya all these all
these places and just dominating and
their sound is really really the
dominant sound so
um yeah it is to to your to your point
you know you have you have different
aspirations and dreams for artists but I
think every artist wants their music
globally you know I mean to me have a
kind of a global sound
how do they make money is it the same
ways that here in the US soaring
merchandise streaming things like that
so they I know they're still trying to
figure out the streaming
um out there but a lot of people make
money from just touring uh doing a lot
of private events weddings
um shows as well
um they haven't it's crazy because I'm
thinking about it now they haven't
really tapped into like the merchandise
and like online
um not that I know of but a lot of um
you know artists out there have you know
some very very big endorsements and they
make a lot of money from endorsements
out there as well
um and um yeah I think they they haven't
really tapped into the online that's
that's pretty interesting because I
haven't really seen that yeah um gives a
big piece of us-based artists right
right is basically you got your touring
you got your streaming Revenue but then
you probably maybe got like some YouTube
or something which is kind of streaming
but really it's like hey can you sell
things to your audience right whether
that's merchandise or other things and
so having a website being able to go
direct all that stuff especially for the
independent artist it's like a huge
piece of it right and I think
endorsements still help as well you know
what I mean a lot of people that want to
channel these uh you know corporations
and want to channel one align their
their brands with you know heavy
endorsements I think that helps as well
too what are the business opportunities
you see whether it's in Ghana or kind of
broader Africa uh if somebody's in
Europe the us maybe live in the Middle
East or Asia South America wherever and
they're looking and they're saying Hey I
want to go and figure out what these
opportunities are like what are the big
areas where you would tell them to go
look this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep good sleep is a game changer
and the age pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
an eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep definitely real estate
for sure that's number one
um
I think real estate is key because it's
like a house deficit
um and I think it's so much opportunity
to build
um skyscrapers you know amusement parks
which I was thinking about doing uh so
much you know undeveloped land that we
can you know tackle together
um another industry that I've been
looking at is the agriculture industry
farming I think you know
as far as when it comes to Agriculture
and food I mean that's not going
anywhere so why not be in an industry
where you can basically you know even if
you just focus on feeding you know
Africa in in general I think that's a
great that's a great Market to go into
as well I'm not too familiar with about
the oil and gas industry but I've been
hearing about the oil and gas industry
as well just going back and forth out
there but um those two those top three
I'll say what about risks so when I was
in uh Nigeria one of the things that uh
I was told uh by the guy who uh who's
kind of taking us around and he was very
clear he's like look it doesn't happen
all the time but he's like there are
definitely situations especially in oil
and gas where there was kidnappings and
all kinds of things that in the United
States most people wouldn't think are uh
you know immediate threats it happens
um but I think that people coming from
other parts of the world that's one of
the things that is just like the fear of
the unknown right same thing in South
America or other places if you're not
familiar with the culture or you may not
know the native language right you don't
have a network of people you're like ah
I don't know so like how do you think
about what risks actually exist versus
maybe what the the thought process of
risk would be I think that all comes
back to who you go out there with and
like what information that you have
before you go into these different type
of businesses I've been hearing a lot of
like crazy stuff happening in the mining
business so I kind of want to stay away
from that you know I've been hearing
some crazy stuff what's the craziest
thing you heard no names uh no names but
I heard that basically they went to a
mind together to mine some um I don't
know if it was uh gold or something else
but and basically they had some people
there that was on the mine that they
went to and saying that this belongs to
them and the people that they went out
there was just like started to fight
about whose land was which and you know
yeah it was gold there whatever it was
there but it's just like just imagine
you going into your your Mining facility
and you trying to mine gold or whatever
you're trying to mind and some people
are there saying that no they that's
just belongs to them so just to fight
Overland I think you just got to be
careful with that
um kidnapping for sure
um and um you know I think in in in in
Africa period you just have to really
really move like low-key until you can
really position yourself to be out there
but that just goes to show like you know
who you go out there with what kind of
you know people is around you what type
of information that you have and um just
knowing what you're about to get
yourself into before you actually do it
when I was in Nigeria uh one of the
happened
for sure two times I remember I think a
third time as well I actually know three
times uh when I came in the country uh
you got to have a paper and I can't
remember if I had a yellow one or a
green one but it basically is vaccines
yellow fever and whatever color I had
everyone else had the other color right
so I mean me and this other guy from
America came two white guys on the plane
right we're going and uh we got to the
woman who was taking the papers and she
was like uh no stop like stand over here
and we stood there for like 25 minutes
and I was like yeah why are we standing
here right everyone else is going by
yeah and then I realized I was like oh I
took twenty dollars I gave it to you
she's like all right go ahead right and
I was like I was like okay got it like
introduction to the country yeah and uh
and I remember being like man like this
place is wild and then uh a couple days
later uh we were at night we were going
to dinner and uh it was me my friend and
then uh our friend who was a Nigerian
and lived in uh Legos and uh uh we were
in an Uber and so we got stopped by the
police oh my gosh as the police officer
got in the car
and he was like pull over here whatever
he had gotten our friend out or whatever
he like made the Uber driver pull over
he was given a whole thing I we didn't
understand what he was saying and so at
some point our friend called like a
cousin whose dad was like at the police
station or something right yeah all
right we're good like they let us go so
oh my God I'm over two in these
situation and then the third one which I
still have the video on my phone uh was
uh we were in Uber coming back we went
to a a wide combinator event in Legos
which in hindsight was like that's like
a hot spot right it's like anyone is not
from Nigeria in the tech industry is
going to be at this event and so I'm
sure what they did is they just set up
checkpoints you know yeah and so when we
were leaving uh we were in an Uber and
uh they they stopped us they made us get
out of the car wow and like you know
again I
I think I'm intelligent enough to know
when you're actually in a dangerous
situation versus like somebody's just
like hey you know you're gonna hang out
here for a little bit and then we'll let
you go and it was very much the ladder I
never felt like I was in danger or
anything like that but they asking for
money yeah and so uh my friend and I
were like you know kind of just like
it's the principle I don't want to give
you any money and you know whatever so I
took my phone out and I started
recording but like recording me and then
I turned out as I were getting shaken
down or whatever and these dudes were
ducking out of the video and
so they're laughing you know what I mean
like it was it was a very friendly
situation given the context yeah but I
remember thinking to myself I was like
man uh this is
something that people talk about in the
western world that just like you don't
get stopped by the police right no no
but on the flip side I've been to a lot
of countries India I've been to all over
Eastern Europe same [ __ ]
it is not a unique thing to uh Nigeria
or an African country this is just
normal human nature right it's actually
a part of the culture
um and and they don't look at it as how
we look at it as correct you know what I
mean like you're just giving money they
look at it as okay like you're supposed
to do this it's a tax basically it's
like a tax yeah but um it is because
that the police system out there are so
underpaid yes right and they feel like
you know they of course they should be
paid higher but it is a tax like you
know you just you pass it through in
America we give the we give the
government the money and then they give
it to the police here's a little bit
more direct he's gonna direct yeah but
but the reason why this is so funny is
because I I have a lot of friends uh who
come from various parts of the world
that live here in the United States now
and one of the the jokes is always
somebody has a relative that when they
got to the United States they got pulled
over for you know whatever they didn't
use their blinker they went a little too
fast or whatever
and they don't realize that's not how
America works and so like I have
multiple friends who would be like my
uncle or my dad or whoever like got
pulled over and he was like oh I got a
bottle of liquor like I'll just give it
to the cop and like he'll let me because
that's what you do in other countries
right yeah yeah the cops here are like
bro that's a bride yeah
it's not cool right yeah and so it as
far as I know every single time a friend
has told me this story it hasn't been a
bad thing it's just like the cops like
no no like that's not what we do here
um but the cultural differences is uh it
to me it it's cool because uh you get to
see that different cultures have
different uh kind of mechanisms
different ways that of how people look
at their relation to other citizens in
their country or their city or whatever
um but it's also it makes it difficult
when people go from the Western World to
let's say Ghana or Nigeria yeah and vice
versa right and so it's just I don't
know it's it's like an education Gap
that more people understand the less
shocking it is when you experience it
right and is is to be honest with you if
you never really experience it it's hard
to tell someone that this is what this
what happens you know what I mean so
like I just tell my friends like you
listen if the police stop you you know
if I'm not there number one just call me
let me know like you know I mean let me
know what was going on but like it's
okay to give them money like that's not
normal now you don't have to give them a
hundred dollars
right but yes it's the tax yeah you know
we we uh we don't look at it as I mean
it is kind of like bribery if you think
about it but it's
in in African culture that's normal
that's just yeah it's a normal thing you
know what I mean it's a tip it's like a
tip you know what I mean tip sounds
better than bribe I think right they
always say like like in Ghana like
something small for the boys so it's a
small for the boys
[Laughter]
that's a saying something small for the
boys small for the boys
you know yo when you see me in the
streets of Ghana I got some ball y'all
I like that though because I think it
also speaks to the fact that like is it
is not predatory in like a malicious way
yeah right into you to what you're
saying is like it's almost more cultural
and no different right now in New York
City we're recording this during the
winter time and uh all my friends in New
York you know what they're talking about
hey bro how much money you giving to the
doorman this year right is it 50 bucks
100 bucks 200 bucks what's appropriate
what's not damn I want to give them just
enough so that they're not mad but I
also don't want to go broke giving them
money you know there's like a cultural
thing in New York city where the doorman
of all of the high-rise buildings
there's an expectation
um if you don't give them money for
Christmas
you you not getting help
oh you need that package get your ass
down here come get it right oh this is
what and again I'm exaggerating to a
degree but like there's this cultural
thing in New York city where the
residents of the high-rise buildings
give money to the doorman and many of
them do it because they're happy to do
it because these people are protecting
them they're helping them they're like
doing all this stuff they're probably
underpaid right so there's this element
of like the residents are going to help
out whatever uh
but until you see it or until you've
lived in a building in New York you
don't really understand it yeah what do
you mean y'all are all debating on much
money to give the doorman and then the
joke is always like bro you think
there's like two door man and then you
realize around Christmas time like man
they got like 12 people
like Christmas gifts and that they
really like the dormants are expecting
that you know what I mean 100 so so when
we look at it as you know it's all jokes
they really expecting that gift and they
might use that for their family whatever
they got to use it for but they really
expecting that gift you know I mean we
laughing about it but they like I'm
really expecting to get something you
know what I mean from a little something
for the boys
that's the greatest phrase I've ever
heard yeah uh all right so when you
think of uh Ghana specifically what are
some of the things that uh you think are
gonna happen over the next couple years
like obviously you've got businesses
there you've got some real estate there
you're spending more time there uh is it
something where uh you're like okay
here's two milestones and this is gonna
be when Ghana kind of arrives on the
global stage or is it a little unclear
at the moment in terms of what those
Milestones would be um no it's it's deaf
class for me I think number one the
infrastructure will be at an all-time
high just because of how fast they're
building now
um I think for sure for sure it'll
definitely be the leading if it's not
going to be the leading but it's
definitely going to be the leading
entertainment uh place in Africa in the
whole Africa uh such as like a Visa
especially for like December uh Easter
now is picking up
um I think in the next few years you'll
definitely see more major companies come
out there and more franchise come out
there as well
um they just opened out their first
uh Burger King is out there now dominoes
came out there KFC is out there they
haven't yet to open a McDonald's yet
there's no McDonald's there's no
McDonald's in Ghana damn can you believe
that yeah McDonald's what's up with that
is it because I got a conversation
haven't been there yet or is it because
Ghana doesn't want McDonald's there I
don't think they understand the
potential yeah interesting I don't I
don't I don't think I think it's
something that you know people have
tried but it hasn't been successful what
about the uh the food and one of the
things I think about is like Americans
are stupid right we think Everyone likes
American food so we're like hey let's go
take McDonald's and put it all over the
world right oh [ __ ] y'all like coffee we
got Starbucks right like whatever
there's a lot of places in the world
like get your shitty ass food out of
here yeah or another thing I love to do
is whenever I travel you go to the
McDonald's in that City and not because
you're trying to get like a cheeseburger
but they actually change some of the
items on the menu based on whatever the
local culture is totally different menu
yeah and so it's just interesting to me
like I remember I went uh in India and
they had a veg and non-vege uh menus
because culturally vegetarian is huge
thing right and so like literally it was
like laid out that way and I was like
man that tell tells you something about
the culture now I didn't get anything
because I'm gonna go eat real food but
like there's like a data point there not
for sure so to not have McDonald's there
or at least not have them be popular I
wonder how much of it is like the people
don't think that food tastes good or or
would go and actually eat it versus
McDonald's hasn't figured out yet
there's a big Market opportunity I I
think
I mean number one we always eat fresh in
in in in Africa right like we have you
know we typically make our own food you
know we cook it it's always gonna be
fresh right but I think just the option
to have a McDonald's for like you know
for the kids to try like it's kids out
there that never ate at McDonald's never
had a Happy Meal never been to the
experience and nothing no cheeseburger
no chicken think if you think about that
that's kind of crazy right so just
having the option to have that
um and they can have different recipes
because you go to McDonald's in you know
London India is different from what we
have here they use like kind of like the
local recipes and mix it up a little bit
you know I know I went to one I think I
was in Sweden or Denmark and they had
mustard and I was like what is this it's
not a cheeseburger yeah I was like I'm
good you know what I mean but like it
was just like different places that I've
been around the world and I kind of like
analyzed like the same thing you do I
analyze the menu to see like okay why
you know and I always question myself is
that why in these places they have this
here but in America we have that right
so for instance in Denmark or Sweden
where I was at they had mustard I was
like I never had a cheeseburger with
mustard on it you know what I mean like
not a McDonald's and I was like well
maybe that's what they like here and
that's what people like normalize as you
know having a cheeseburger instead of
ketchup they had mustard so I was like
oh [ __ ] so this is like the new thing
out there you know what I mean like for
me I didn't like it because I'm used to
like ketchup right but
um I think you know
to go back to your point is that
we need to just have the option for kids
to you know try it you know what I mean
have the option for if you whether you
like coffee have a Starbucks there just
so that you know you know foreigners or
anybody come out there they say hey can
I go to Starbucks yes Starbucks and they
got one yeah they got one then I cry
more no they don't have a slower but I'm
just saying if if they did have a
Starbucks or Dunkin Donuts that would be
an option for someone like yourself if
you love Starbucks that wants to come to
Ghana you feel more like okay for more
at home you know me a little bit uh I
think it's tourism there very big very
big yes it's increasing
um now that December has been like the
you know like the popular eyes the place
that goes Ghana a lot of people is
coming back and they'll come back
throughout the year because now December
prices Skyrocket so you might be able to
get a flight in July that's half the
cost in December a round trip what is it
from like a New York or Miami uh
commercial fund well New York on Delta
last time I check it was about about
2700 one way
wow
um yeah the gun is so expensive it's
crazy we gotta talk about that too like
Airlines is Anthony I mean with fees and
everything that's like six grand just to
get there that was it was expensive and
then
um
I looked at first class and it was like
four forty five hundred to five grand
one was about 10 grand especially in
December it's like ridiculous yeah
because the weather is what is uh like
relatively mild uh yeah during December
yeah and December is pretty pretty nice
but just because of the festival season
um it picks back up again like April
tickets go Skyrocket again for like
Easter
um January kind of tends to be lower but
my question is to the airlines is that
why is it so expensive to go to Africa
is actually more expensive to go to
Africa than it is to go to Dubai and I'm
kind of like I don't understand why is
it so you know expensive to go there is
it because they don't have because I
know they have the you know they have
the fleet to do it right I know they
have you know people booking just that
like their prices is like you know
skyrocketed the same difference the same
uh distance say no it's actually Dubai
is longer it's farther farther yeah
that's crazy yeah so it's like it
doesn't make any sense when you look at
it you think there's a conspiracy
I think that you know they
number one the demand is there so
whatever the prices are people are going
to pay for it you want to get back home
they want to see their family and you
know buy Coastal whatever business
people are going to pay for it but I
just don't understand why is it priced
the way it's priced I like to have it
sit down and like talk about that well
people are gonna pay [ __ ] they're gonna
raise the prices yeah but it should be
like unfortunately unfortunately and
it's like another thing is too is only
like couple direct flights which you
know United now has you know direct
flights Delta has direct flights but
there's no other airlines that has
direct flights you either got to stop a
London Amsterdam Dubai you know to go no
nine hours nine hours from New York yeah
that's nine hours and 30 minutes like
once you get to like the nine hour mark
That's like just long enough for you
like hey maybe I want to go through
London yeah chill a little I mean I did
it a couple times non-stop I was like
[ __ ] I should have stopped
but yeah I mean it's it's it's it's a
great place to you know a great place to
visit you know I mean family is super
safe
um I think that's another thing that you
know people are going back there's
definitely a safe
safe place uh when we say safe uh in
Legos uh I stayed uh so most of the
people who are Taurus and uh Legos they
stay at Victoria Island right uh I
stayed um on the mainland maybe like uh
a mile or so uh from computer Village
okay uh so like further in and I
remember I was a little uh like oh [ __ ]
did we make a mistake when we first got
to the first night yeah and then we
pulled up to the hotel and had a gate
and there was armed uh guys with AK-47
standing at the gate and I had actually
two takeaways one was like uh why do you
all need armed guards standing at the
gate right and the second one was like
if somebody comes up here and starts
shooting I don't think you guys appear
to be the dudes you're gonna be shooting
back like it sounds like you all may run
so like now I'm double worried right
yeah but uh uh there was a sense of like
safety because there's a big Iron Gate
around the place there's armed guards
whatever like it's the same thing in
Ghana or that's not necessary no not
necessarily yeah God is more like I said
it's more chilled and calm yeah Nigeria
just have a tense they're more
aggressive than ghanaians I'll say that
for all every single Nigerian listens
there's gonna be like no we're not yeah
but they are they have a tendency to be
more aggressive and that's just normal
just their coaches with how they grew up
New York versus LA right you know what I
mean just how you grew up just your
culture just your people around you just
what you know right but they're not bad
people but it's just a little bit
um I'll say well people from L.A don't
like New York right like living in New
York and people from New York don't
really like living in L.A because it's a
different pace
I think this with that being said is
kind of a little bit more dangerous than
Ghana so people a lot of you see a lot
of Nigerians now are flying to gun and
getting places to live and I think it's
like the poverty Gap you know I mean
um in Nigeria is like bigger than God or
so because of more people yeah yeah how
many people are in Ghana 12 no 24
million last 24 yeah okay so so like uh
basically three New York cities
and then what's up with uh crypto I
think that uh there's a lot of people in
the Bitcoin or crypto 32 million
actually 32. okay as a as a as of
December 22 32 million oh wow four New
York cities basically yeah that's pretty
big
um there's a lot of people who point to
a Nigeria or Ghana as uh this is a prime
example of a place where these
Technologies uh or something like
Bitcoin could have a massive of positive
impact when you go what do you see do
you see people using it are you curious
but not using it like what's on the
ground it's actually it's actually super
super crazy because on the ground there
now a lot of people are getting
accustomed to using crypto now and
there's also a lot of people that don't
know crypto so I think just having an
acceptable in Africa like Africa a lot
of people use it to do like you know
minor transactions nothing like major
yet but I think when it comes to that
mainstream and like and to be accepted
by the government it's just that once
they don't know about it they don't want
to accept it they think it's like
illegal you know things happening which
you know crypto is crypto right but I
think
it's definitely definitely being used a
lot in in Africa I mean especially in
Nigeria and Ghana
um just because of how quick and Swift
the transactions go
um we have something called mobile money
in um in Ghana where I just need your
phone number and I can basically send
you money like how we send sales here
right but it's it has like a cap it has
like a limit
um but it's pretty impressive when you
think about it because it was using that
before we was using Zell
yeah that's kind of crazy and that's how
they was moving their money around but
now with crypto where I could be you
know I could be in New York I could be
in La I could be in Miami and I could
just send a transaction and they could
receive it instantly they kind of
understanding and seeing how powerful
that is right so you know I'm trying to
implement that to real estate into
different businesses to understand that
hey it's not a bad thing to accept
crypto here because you know with mobile
money sometimes you're not able to
access that large large sum of money you
know from a bank perspective or from you
know getting your money out perspective
with crypto you can actually get your
money out I mean of course like usdt you
know the leading ones but
um yeah it's it's impressive that people
are using a lot yeah for sure and is it
mostly young people yeah and that's why
the internet penetration mobile usage
young people who are interested in this
stuff or is the government and kind of
businesses they're interested as well a
lot of young people younger people yeah
older people kind of you know it's like
stuck in their ways they really don't
understand it yet yeah but
um I think it's always us to like you
know change it change it a mentality and
change a cycle has the government been
embracing it abrasive to it or they're
kind of agnostic yeah it kind of it's
not like they're not really embracing it
as yet but they're kind of understanding
you know the movements and like
making sure that they they have some
type of you know one skin they must get
out in the game like a crypto but they
they they're seeing it being used you
know I mean I think Nigeria kind of like
banded and unbanded and you know
different things like that but I know
all my friends in Ghana there they're
really really you know Advanced when it
comes to crypto and Forex for sure yeah
it's pretty interesting who are the most
like uh successful or well-known
ghanians in America like if you had to
pick two or three people who do you
think when you say like well known like
business individuals business music uh
movies celebrity just just like
if they go back people are like
we're proud that they are Argonian
um I think mostly like the football
players
um
a lot of like soccer players but like I
mean to be honest with you a lot of
people are proud of like just like what
you know because For Me Myself and like
Michael Blackson like the people that's
out here that's like gone in we always
try to go back and like give back you
know what I mean so anybody's just going
back and giving back I think they're
pretty you know they're pretty known
yeah it's interesting because in America
like we don't really think about uh
Americans going and doing things in
other uh countries with the same Pride
maybe uh we think about it in the sense
of like sports so Olympics things like
that right but uh if we saw an American
who was doing something crazy in London
people are like hey yo that's American
right yeah right but but other countries
there's this like nationalistic Pride
that actually in some ways Americans
should be and many are envious of right
in that uh when you have citizens that
rally around you know we're more similar
than different I think it's such a
powerful thing yeah and it's almost one
of the things I wish Americans had more
right like we can again we care about
sports we care about some of these
aspects uh obviously we just saw the
Brittany Greiner and Paul Whalen and
this whole situation
um but but it's different right when you
talk to somebody from a Nigeria Ghana
South Africa whatever like when they see
somebody from their country go and do
something great in the world whether
sports or not they're like super proud
it's the culture that we live in and
like how we uh Pride food from knowing
where we come from and knowing that you
know someone is in the western or still
representing representing like the
country I think that's where it comes
from and then like you know it's a huge
like soccer football you know their fans
are super you know super in depth of
like just voting for their country so I
think that has an exp uh um a part
taking that as well because we have like
sports here where it's just like cities
they have like a country that's
important you know what I mean like it's
kind of like different if you think
about it like you know it's like okay
what's your favorite team okay no this
is my soccer team that this is my
country's team you know what I mean uh
the Black Star so I think it's you know
um that has a major effect as well
because they're like supporting their
country and um you know soccer is like
the biggest sport out there
um
but yeah I think you know people are
prideful and people you know they love
to say that you know they're African and
whether it's from Ghana or whether it's
from Nigeria was from South Africa but
you know
um people don't notice the Elon is South
African yeah yeah it's like people don't
know you know what I mean yeah well and
I think that uh the only time it ever
comes up uh what whether fortunately
unfortunately depending on how you view
it is uh people will crack jokes and say
things like oh uh an African-American
owns uh Twitter now or something right
yeah and like I get it the internet
culture whatever uh but there is this
thing of like um whether you look at
Elon and and he didn't come straight to
America from South Africa he went to
Canada and in the whole thing uh there's
many other entrepreneurs who have done
something very similar uh but also like
the fortune uh I think it's the Fortune
500 I think is is the uh grouping 50 of
the CEOs are uh immigrants I think yeah
it's either that or is uh of billion
dollar companies fifty percent of the
CEOs are immigrants there's some some
Metric on I'll get it wrong
um and then if you actually look at like
you know who runs some of these uh
businesses like who's running Google
who's running Microsoft right these are
not american-born uh Executives these uh
in many cases uh recently has been
people from India but these are folks
who came from outside of our country and
came here right which if you look at the
history of America like well hey news
flash [ __ ] what you all think
been happening in America for you know
250 plus years right other places coming
here and doing awesome things and so
like it's more uh the trend line than it
is you know some outlier situation right
I think the opportunity that when you
come from a different country and you
realize opportunity that you can you
know tackle out here it makes you want
to wake work way way harder and smarter
and then you kind of understand that you
know culturally you kind of understand
that you didn't have this opportunity in
this country so you have to make you all
on your best when you have opportunity
in the western world and vice versa
right well the it's American going back
to Africa to do an investment they know
that they have the Western world but it
may not worked out so when they go out
there to figure out the opportunity in
Africa they put their all in and I think
that's what we are seeing as far as the
transition for younger younger Americans
African descent
it's uh it's fantastic where can we send
people to find you on the internet PJ
Kev
um Instagram Twitter is PJ Kev approve
and my website is pjcav.com and uh if
they're interested in Jets Jets approved
Jets is my company charter at approve
hyphenjets.com Charter at approve
hyphenjets.com awesome man I appreciate
you coming appreciate you appreciate you
guys for having me I learned something
every single time so we're definitely
bringing your ass back I mean I need
more knowledge information is key
information is key appreciate it